my name's 10 I'm the principal role far
officer for the district why makers
district leaders the fire season is
finally heating up after a wet spring
under these hot dry windy conditions
it's very easy for a fight to get out of
control if you were found responsible
for a fire such as this you could well
be held liable and where the cost of
containing in distinguishing that far
so please think before your light here
are some tips that you might think about
before you light a fire the waimakariri
district is now under a restricted choir
season
this means that no fires in the open are
to be left without a permanent check out
the video link for life for more
information if you're on the lifestyle
block or farm check the weather forecast
before lighting far too many fires last
year will fall asleep started when
strong winds were predicted keep a house
nearby charged and ready for immediate
use and keep 10 to 30 meters clearance
around buildings and houses remember the
more you feed it the bigger fire grows
don't miss around the fire because when
it gets out of control things get very
bad very fast just because it's no
longer smoking doesn't mean it's out
fires can smolder for months so before
leaving chick by putting your hand in
the ashes if the ashes are still warm
I've been up for a house in it and with
it down thoroughly we don't want a
repeat of previous year's mistakes so to
ensure we all have a great summer
please think before you light for more
information about the restricted fire
season and applying for a permit
please visit waimakariri givt down easy
[Music]